es ist soweit der deutsche astronaut
alexander gerst hat sich heute mittwoch
den 6 juni zusammen mit zwei weiteren
kollegen auf dem weg zur raumstation iss
gemacht zur internationalen raumstation
eines der meist gewünschten dem die er
mir hier über whatsapp geschickt habt
ist die frage warum die ss überhaupt
sichtbar ist die erklärung dazu gibt es
jetzt auf einem noch ein paar tipps und
tricks um die iss zu beobachten und zu
fotografieren herzlich willkommen bei
pixum science and fiction und vielen
dank für den artikel vorschlag
ja viele von euch wissen es sicher die
iss kann man unter ganz bestimmten
bedingungen tatsächlich mit dem bloßen
auge erkennen ganz ohne teleskop dabei
ist sie rund 400 kilometer von der erde
entfernt doch mit ihrem solarpanels ist
sie in etwa so groß wie ein ganzes
fußballfeld und dementsprechend im
fussball 90 minuten braucht die station
also eine spiellänge um mit 28.800
stundenkilometern die erde einmal zu
umrunden für die astronauten und
astronauten die auf ihr leben und
arbeiten bedeutet das dass sie pro tag
16 sonnenauf und untergänge zu sehen
bekommen alexander gerst soll übrigens
187 tage auf der iss arbeiten und leben
und am mittwoch um 13 uhr 12
mitteleuropäischer zeit geht es oder ist
es für ihn an bord einer sojus rakete
vom kasachischen weltraumbahnhof
baikonur gegangen mit dabei ein
ehemaliger kampfpilot aus russland und
eine amerikanische medizinerinnen und
ingenieurin der flug zur iss soll zwei
tage dauern
doch wie können wir hier von der erde
die station verfolgen die 109 meter
spannweite der station reflektieren das
sonnenlicht und richtig gut zu erkennen
ist sie nur morgens oder abends und zwar
wenn sie sich wieder im erdschatten noch
auf der anderen seite der erde befindet
dann sieht sie aus wie ein heller stern
am himmel der lautlos über ihn hinweg
zieht und zwar innerhalb weniger minuten
die station wird dann vom sonnenlicht
angestrahlt doch der himmel ist in der
dämmerung noch oder schon dunkel die esa
hat einen trecker auf ihrer webseite der
genau zeigt wo sich die station gerade
befindet darunter ist auch direkt die
stelle auf der erde zu sehen über den
sie sich gerade befindet wenn nachts
keine wolken am himmel sind ist die
raumstation von dieser stelle aus mit
bloßem auge zu sehen
auch ihre genaue flugroute also aus
welcher richtung sie kommt über welche
orte sie fliegt und wie lange sie
sichtbar ist dazu gibt es im internet
viele verschiedene seiten eine
empfehlung bekommt er von mir und zwar
zu der folgenden seite der nasa
gps doppelpunkt ashley scott station
dort nasa dot com / ja und was
doppelpunkt auf englisch heißt das
schreibt er mehr in die kommentare
hier könnt ihr einfach eine größere
stadt in eurer nähe angeben und schon
durch angezeigt an welchem tag und zu
welcher uhrzeit ihr die iss am besten
sehen können zudem gibt es infos dazu ob
sie eher flach am horizont fliegt oder
aber steil am himmel entlang merken
könnt ihr euch jedenfalls schon mal dass
sie es immer aus der westlichen
richtungen kommt also daher wo die sonne
untergegangen ist wenn er sie beobachten
volt machte sinn einen möglichst dunklen
stand auch zu wählen wenn andere
lichtquellen wie straßenlaternen könnten
euch stören kombat zum fotografieren
einfach auf den auslöser drücken reicht
hier leider nicht denn dann habt ihr
nachher bloß einen kleinen hellen punkt
auf den auf dunklem hintergrund welt
deswegen eine längere belichtungszeit
aus beispielsweise eine minute lang
und dann könnt ihr euch verdenken
vielleicht denken was passiert dann habt
ihr mich quasi eine leuchtspur am himmel
festgehalten und richtig cool kann das
foto dann werden wenn ihr euch noch
einen weiteren schönen hingucker für den
forderungen organisierten baumhaus
dächer oder spitzen kirchturm
andersherum geht das ganze übrigens auch
wenn er also bock habt von der iss die
erde zu sehen klickt euch mal rum im
netz denn tatsächlich sendet sie bilder
live zur erde
manchmal kann man dabei sogar den
astronauten bei der arbeit zugucken
außerdem gibt es auch die möglichkeit
den funk sprich verkehr mit den
kontrollzentren auf der erde mit
anzuhören wenn ihr kein video zur
raumfahrt und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp nur dann verpasst ihr kein
video denn die abo box auf youtube.de
ist ja mal ein bisschen glück in haft
über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch
vor allen andern vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert ihr kriegt also
vorher eine meldung und zur begrüßung
habe ich noch ein kleines geschenk für
euch einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs
um social and media abonnieren das geht
hier erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der
social media welt aber nicht die
genau die glocken vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
felton harry die revolution der
raumfahrt bis dann würde ich mal sagen
bleibt dran